sur le site de Vélizy de safran c'est
les trains d'atterrissage qui occupent
les collaborateurs de safran ici et pour
en parler nous sommes avec Patrick
joyeuse bonjour bonjour directeur
technique et arrêter de safran à landing
system alors tout d'abord déjà c'est
quoi un travail d'atterrissage alors ça
fera un système nous offrons des
systèmes d'atterrissage complet donc on
parle de train d'atterrissage comme on
voit derrière moi
donc les structures principales qui
supportent l'avion lors de la phase de
d'atterrissage qui amortisse l'énergie
au sol et puis qui supporte l'avion
pendant toute la phase de roulage au sol
et lors du décollage mais c'est pas
seulement le train d'atterrissage c'est
aussi les roues et les freins et tout le
système de freinage et ce qui permet
également de replier et détendre le
les trains d'atterrissage dans les
phases après le décollage et avant
l'atterrissage alors en quoi aujourd'hui
le système
est-il polluant alors le système
d'atterrissage n'est pas polluant en
tant que tel c'est une grosse structure
il se trouve que c'est l'équipement qui
qui est le plus lourd au niveau de la
masse avide de l'avion donc un système
d'atterrissage complet ça représente
entre 5 et 6 % de la masse à vide de
l'avion et donc il est très utile et
indispensable lors des phases de
déplacement au sol de l'avion et lors de
évidemment de l'atterrissage mais
pendant toute la phase de vol et de
croisière finalement on transporte un
bagage inutile et ce bagage contribue à
la consommation carburant de la viande
donc on fait énormément d'activités pour
alléger nos trains d'atterrissage et les
rendre plus
eco friendly si je puis dire alors l'un
des moyens justement vous parlez de
matériaux qui sont qui sont pesants
c'est de changer de matériaux peut-être
de les rendre un peu plus légers ou même
carrément de changer de passer de
l'acier à autre chose en fait absolument
alors il y a plusieurs défis qui qui ont
lieu en ce moment d'une part les
l'architecture des avions va évoluer
dans le futur pour des avions plus
allégés donc avec des ailes plus fines
etc donc tout le système d'accrochage du
train sur l'avion va être repensé et les
trains d'atterrissage en tant que tel
vont voir apparaître des nouveaux
matériaux des composites de deuxième
génération pour véritablement alléger
ses structure et faire en sorte que le
bagage qu'on transporte pendant la
croisière et le plus faible possible
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres moyens aussi
de rendre peut-être un peu plus
décarbonée l'avion à travers les trains
d'atterrissage oui alors au niveau des
systèmes de freinage on a commencé il y
a bien longtemps déjà avec les freins
carbone qui prennent une part
grandissante du marché ça fera le
système de fournit que des freins
carbone sur ses avions ça permet une
très grande économie de masse et dans
les procédés de fabrication du carbone
également nous innovons pour réduire la
consommation d'énergie et de gaz utilisé
pour pour fabriquer ces matériaux une
deuxième une deuxième avancée c'est
l'électrification de nos systèmes
électrifier les systèmes permet
d'alléger la masse des systèmes
hydrauliques de l'avion et donc c'est un
véritable contributeur en plus
d'améliorer la disponibilité
opérationnelle des produits une question
aussi parce que s'affranche c'est un
grand groupe
faire un avion sur les moteurs
travailler à la fois sur le moteur
travailler sur les trains d'atterrissage
il y a beaucoup d'éléments sur lesquels
on peut avoir un pouvoir justement pour
aller vers un avion plus vert comment
vous travaillez tous ensemble les
différentes filiales ça fera landing
system ça prend aircraft engine
s'affronter alors concevoir les
technologies de demain c'est un
véritable sport d'équipe donc on a ici
sur le site de Vélizy plus de 600
ingénieurs et on travaille tous ensemble
à développer ces nouvelles technologies
et d'ailleurs nous recrutons toujours
pour développer les nouveaux procédés
qui seront plus respectueux de
l'environnement et toutes ces
technologies que vous avez vu
aujourd'hui donc notamment nous avons
l'avion des métiers au Bourget dans
lequel nous allons recruter des
centaines d'ingénieurs donc cette année
nous nous recrutons plus de 1000 postes
sur safran landing systems donc on a un
véritable de challenge collectif à
réussir la décarbonation de l'aviation
voilà vous recrutiez quel type de profil
ingénieur des ingénieurs mais pas
seulement également des professions
achats matériaux et procédés
une grande variété de
métiers
et nécessaire à la réussite de nos
projets et sur le lien que vous avez
avec les autres entités de safran
peut-être est-ce que vous travaillez
aussi ensemble oui alors nous avons
notamment une technologie que nous que
nous préparons pour la future génération
de plateforme qui est le tactilage
électrique emblématique donc pour
pouvoir déplacer les les avions au sol
sans l'usage des moteurs principaux et
nous dans cette ce projet de recherche
nous travaillons main dans la main avec
les autres filiales de safran comme
safran electrical and power ventilation
system transmission system pour
concevoir ces produits qui mettent en
jeu l'ensemble des équipements de
l'avion et j'ai lu dans la presse qu'on
pourrait même aller jusqu'à
l'autonomie c'est à dire qu'il y aurait
le pilote toujours à bord bien
évidemment mais que le taxiège pour
faciliter disons les choses pourrait se
faire de manière autonome comme on déjà
la technologie dans l'automobile oui
c'est un grand c'est une grande avancée
de l'aviation c'est de rendre les
opérations les plus simples et
optimisées possible donc l'automation
permet justement de d'alléger la charge
des pilotes et d'améliorer les
consommations carburant l'empreinte
environnementale donc c'est vraiment un
grand enjeu de l'aviation de demain et
c'est tous les travaux qui se déroulent
ici sur le site de Vélizy également
Vélizy et puis avec nos collaborateurs
dans le monde entier évidemment et avec
l'aide des avionneurs nous ne
travaillons pas tout seul merci beaucoup
Patrick joyeuse merci avec plaisir
directeur technique et arrêter de safran
landing system